breaking news from the war in ukraine at
least six people were killed in this
russian attack on a shopping mall in
kiev the latest of many acts of violence
which appear to be targeting civilians
in the heart-hit city of mariupol
hundreds of miles southeast of the
capital russia offered to let civilians
escape if ukraine would let it take over
the city
ukraine's government said no to that mts
taeb is in la viv ukraine with more on
this part of the story mts good morning
to you
gail good morning well president
zielinski calling on vladimir putin for
what he's calling face-to-face talks but
the kremlin is saying more progress
needs to be made first in this war which
is now being called a bloody stalemate a
warning some of the images in this
report are quite distressing
in the heart of keeve and infertile
after russian shelling targeted this
shopping center overnight killing at
least six
by morning and the devastation is near
total
but it's in mariopol where the horrific
scale of vladimir putin's war on ukraine
is laid bare this once thriving southern
seaport home to nearly half a million is
now a wasteland
the bitter battle for the strategically
important city on the sea of azov was
captured in all its intensity in this
video from a ukrainian militant group
it appears to show them shooting
directly at a russian tank
for civilians the violence has been
catastrophic there are now so many
bodies volunteers are left with little
choice but to bury them wherever they
can including by the side of a road but
it's in mary opal's basements where the
living remain
we've been here for 11 days she says we
have some food and some firewood but in
a week we'll have nothing what should we
do
the fall of mariupol would be a
significant victory for vladimir putin's
war
it would allow russian forces stationed
across southern ukraine to connect with
soldiers in the east of the country
but at what cause artem just two has
shrapnel wounds in his stomach he and
other wounded children from mariupol
have been taken to this hospital
a six-year-old boy was shrapped on his
head described without any emotion how
his mother burned to death in their car
after it was hit he said to his dad buy
me a new mom i want someone to walk me
to school
at the saint george church in the
western city of david
anguish at the horrors across ukraine
father pablo
is a priest here my heart is broken
i cry all time
because i can understand
why
what a reason but i
i know that i
need to be a strong
and i need to help the people
vladimir putin's war is now in its
fourth week
but it's the people of ukraine who
continue to show strength in their
suffering as they pray for this living
nightmare to end
now according to the un 10 million
ukrainians have now been displaced by
the fighting 10
million that's nearly a quarter of the
country's population with three and a
half million of them now refugees living
abroad nate
you were right those images are
absolutely heartbreaking mts tayyip
western ukraine thank you